Well, good morning again, church.
It is a joy to be with you today to see you here.
If you're new to our church especially, we are honored
that you take that step of faith.
We'd love to meet you. Uh,
there's a new here area out there in the lobby.
And just to introduce yourself
and us, to introduce ourselves to you, love to get that
together if we can.
Today though, we're continuing our series
through the book of one Samuel.
It's called He Shall Reign.
And we're gonna be in chapter 22 today, one Samuel 22.
So if you're not there already, go ahead and turn there.
One Samuel 22.
Now this morning's sermon will be kind of a tough one.
Uh, some questions will be raised.
Uh, we'll see very blatant evil in the text.
We'll have to think pretty deeply about some things.
And so I think it'd be good for us to pray
before we get too far into this to ask the Lord to teach us,
uh, where we need to understand and
and to, to give us trust
where we can't understand some things today.
So pray with me. God, thank you for your word,
that we don't have to wonder who you are
or wonder about you.
Even though you are incomprehensible, you are
beyond our understanding.
We don't have to wonder about your character
and about your nature.
And you've shown us that you've taught us that.
So teach us from your word Holy Spirit.
Teach us in the deepest parts of who we are. Change us.
Open our eyes to see what we need to see today
and give us trust where we can't fully comprehend it.
In Jesus' name. Amen.
So if you remember where we're at in this narrative,
we remember David, he's on the run from King Saul.
'cause King Saul is jealous of God's anointing on David at
as Saul's replacement as the king of Israel.
And so Saul is after him trying to kill him.
And last week we saw David make some questionable decisions
as he was running from Saul.
He appeared to trust his own craftiness rather than
trusting God fully.
He stretched the truth with the priest.
He did some things to manipulate others, it seems.
And so we see that, that he did that and,
and the consequences of those actions didn't show up
immediately, but they do today
and we'll see 'em very clearly here today.
So look at what we see here.
This is what we see in the text.
We just walk through it and a piece by piece will get there.
But, but what happened now
that David had been sent back into Judah,
he'd fled to other nations.
The pre the, the prophet told him to go back to Judah.
And so he has now, he's growing in his trust of the Lord.
What do we see happen here?
Well, first we see a king in turmoil.
We'll see a king in turmoil as we start this passage,
one Samuel 22, starting in verse six through verse eight.
Now Saul heard that David was discovered,
meaning he'd shown himself
and the men who were with him,
Saul was sitting at Gibbon under the Tamara tree on the
height with his spear in his hand, which we've seen
that's not going well at any point in this story.
But all his servants were standing about him
and Saul said to his servants,
who stood about him here Now people of Benjamin,
will the son of Jesse give every one
of you fields and vineyards?
Will he make you all commanders of thousands
and commanders of hundreds that all
of you have conspired against me?
No one discloses
to me when my son makes a covenant with the son of Jesse.
None of you is sorry for me
or discloses to me
that my son has stirred up my servant against me
to lie in weight as at this day.
So you see Saul, he's in turmoil here, right?
First he accused his troops of conspiring against him
and he's tossing around these ideas
of bribes all over the place
as if he was some other nation's king
because that's the way they worked.
He was talking about like any other nation would follow
their gods, not Yahweh.
They would use bribes. They would use manipulation.
And he's talking about as if that's the way David
and he were even doing it.
But then he also comes across as pretty whiny, doesn't he?
Like he's almost pouting here.
You can imagine like a a a baby crying
and that kind of feeling
and the sound like nobody told me about Jonathan
and David, right?
Nobody told me nobody feels bad for me.
Like he's just whining to his troops here.
But he was wrong, right? Because David was not
trying to kill him.
David could have, but he didn't.
Saul was just paranoid thinking, I'm about
to lose my position.
He's paranoid. And so he is
whining, he's in turmoil.
But then verse nine we'll get to in a moment calls back
to something we almost kind
of skipped over last week in chapter 21
that there was a soldier who did know,
like there was a soldier in the know, at least partially.
We'll figure that out here in a second.
But, but he was saying nobody told me there was one person
in his army who did know.
Look at verses nine and 10
then answered dog, the mite who stood
by the servants of Saul.
I saw the son of Jesse coming to Knob to a Alek, the son
of a, a high tube.
And he inquired to the Lord for him and gave him provisions
and gave him the sword of Goliath, the Philistine.
Now you remember last week when David goes
to visit the priest, there was this one little verse kind
of in the middle of everything
that we didn't really look too deeply.
It introduced a character out of nowhere.
This was chapter 21 verse seven.
As David comes to knob, now, a certain man of the servants
of Saul was there that day detained before the Lord.
His name was dog Dite, the chief of Saul's herdsman.
So it doesn't really tell us why,
but what we know is that dog was there in knob when David
came to the priest asking for food and asking for weapons.
And so that's what Doug told Saul here in chapter 22, right?
He's like, I saw him, but the way he said it
to Saul made the priest a alek sound like a conspirator.
Uh, he was in on it. He was given Saul weapons
or given David weapons giving David food.
He was in on it.
But we as readers, we know that wasn't true, right?
There was no collusion.
It was David stretching the truth that Alek was just doing
what he was supposed to do.
But then notice when do reports it to Saul,
he adds an element saying the priest inquired of the Lord
for David, which we don't really know
if that actually happened or not.
It doesn't say that in chapter 21.
Now here's how it might have come about.
It may have been that
because Goliath sword, you remember in chapter 21,
Goliaths sword was wrapped in the efo, this this uh,
fabric that they would use to actually inquire of the Lord.
So when maybe do saw all of that happen,
the Goliaths sword he knew was in there
and it came out with the efo unwrapped.
That's maybe why he assumed Alek had inquired of the Lord.
But that's actually a really important piece
of the puzzle here because what was common
among the kings in that time in the nations around them was
that the king had to know every time someone inquired
of their gods,
like anybody in the whole nation, if they inquired
of the God, the king better know about it.
So when Dogue said that ah, Alek had inquired of God
without Saul knowing about it, that infuriated Saul,
which again proved
that Saul was acting like every other nation's king
except the way Yahweh wanted him to act, right?
Saul at this point had become exactly
what Samuel had warned the people the king was going
to become back in chapter eight.
Remember Samuel said, Hey guys, this is what's
gonna happen if you let this happen.
If this Saul, if a king comes, here's how it's gonna go.
Saul is the picture of what he was warning them about.
He'd become like every other king.
Well watch how Saul responded.
Now verses 11 through 15, he's brought the priest in
who was involved with David.
Look at verse 11. Then the king sent to summon a Alek,
the priest, the son of a high, a high tube,
and all his father's house.
The priests who were at knob, all of them came to the king.
That's important in a moment.
And Saul said, he's speaking just
to the one priest here now son of a high tube.
And he answered, here I am my Lord.
And Saul said to him, why have you conspired against me,
you and the son of Jesse, that you have given him bread
and a sword and have inquired of God for him so
that he has risen against me
to lie in weight as at this day.
And Alek answered the king.
And who among all your servants is so faithful as David,
who is the king's son-in-law and captain over your bodyguard
and honored in your house?
Is today the first time that I've inquired of God for him?
No, let not the king impute anything to his servant
or to all the house of my father,
for your servant has known nothing
of all this much or little.
And so what we see is the questioning of the priest, right?
The priest comes in and he's a priest in question.
He's getting grilled by King Saul,
similarly accusing him of conspiracy
wrongly assuming David's after Saul.
And so he's like, everybody's against me. Who is involved?
Let's go after them. So
how the priest respond though, you see it right?
There was, there was a clear respect for David.
He knew David was this honored man,
but then almost sarcastically to Saul,
he denies all the charges.
I didn't do it, man. Like why? Why would you think I would?
And he wasn't lying, right?
He, he wasn't trying to cover his, he had no need
to cover his tracks.
He had done nothing wrong.
He was upstanding in everything he had done.
There was nothing to hide.
Sadly though, watch the fury of the king.
We see next a king respond in
fury starting in verse 16.
And the king said, you shall surely die a alek you
and all your father's house.
And the king said to the guard who stood about him turn
and kill the priest of the Lord
because their hand also is with David.
And they knew that he fled and did not disclose it to me.
But the servants of the king would not put out their hand
to strike the priests of the Lord.
And so the king said to do you turn and strike the priests
and do the mite turned
and struck down the priests and he killed.
On that day, 85 persons who wore the linen iffa
and knob, the city of the priest, he put to the sword,
both man and woman, child
and infant, ox, donkey and sheep.
He put to the sword
like, what a tragedy.
Isn't it such
destruction, suffering?
I said it last week. Sin has consequences.
And it's interesting that Saul's soldiers
seemingly had more fear of the Lord than Saul did.
They wouldn't touch the priests.
They, they knew they were supposed to stay away from that.
And they were, they weren't gonna touch the
priest but but do.
Right? Seeing an opportunity to curry favor with the king,
he gladly executed the king's orders
and many, many people died.
See, this is why we read the whole Bible in context.
Sadly, Saul did to the priests of Yahweh
what he wouldn't do with the Amalekites.
If you remember back in chapter 15, the enemies
of God who God said wipe them out,
Saul was like, nah, I don't, I don't need,
but he does it with the priests of God.
Like you see how far he's fallen.
But here's the thing, we, we look at scenes like this
and it's really easy for us to judge the supposed fairness
of a situation like this.
And it's tragic. We'll come back to that in a second.
But we can't forget something.
Again, we read in context something happened early
in First Samuel.
Do you remember who the priest was at the very beginning
of the book of one Samuel?
It was Eli. And he had two sons
who were also priests.
And those sons, if you remember, were incredibly wicked.
Like they were stealing from people
as they brought offerings.
There was rampant sexual immorality all over the place.
And the Bible even claims
that they were called worthless men.
They did not even know the Lord.
It says like priests in the temp tabernacle
says they didn't even know God.
They were worthless.
And so what it talked about, if you remember,
was God held wrath toward them
and toward Eli as a result of their actions,
their total disregard for God.
There was wrath toward them.
And one Samuel 2 25 says it was God's will
to put those priests to death.
But that wasn't all we, we get it.
Like that's what they should have deserved for
that in a sense, right?
But it was similar to
how we've watched God reject Saul's house
because of his unbelief.
He's not gonna be the king. His
family's not gonna be the king anymore.
God rejected his house.
Similarly, God rejected Eli
and his house from the priesthood as well.
It's what one Samuel two verse 31 says,
behold the days are coming when I will cut
off your strength.
This is to Eli, your strength
and the strength of your father's house so
that there will not be an old man in your house.
Then in distress you will look
with envious eye on all the prosperity
that shall be bestowed on Israel.
There shall not be an old man in your house forever.
The only one
of you whom I shall not cut off from my altar shall be
spared to weep his eyes out to grieve his heart.
And all the descendants of your house shall die
by the sword of men.
Now think about it, who were the descendants of Eli?
It was the priest, a alek and all his family.
He was the great grandson of Eli.
And so do you see what just happened here in chapter 22,
Saul And do they were fully guilty
and responsible
for murdering the priests and their families.
Yet at the same time, God was super intending all of that
as judgment on Eli's house fulfilling
what he said was coming.
And I get it. That's, that's a difficult concept.
We'll come back to that in a moment,
but that's, that's what we see clearly
stated as what was happening.
But there's one more scene in chapter 22 that we need
to catch before we dig into that topic.
And it was actually predicted back in chapter two in
that scene I just read, look at one Samuel 22
verses 20 through 23 to the end of that chapter, watch this.
But one of the sons of a Alek, the son
of a high tube named Abiathar, he escaped and fled
after David and Abiathar told David
that Saul had killed the priest of the Lord.
And David said to Abiathar, I knew on
that day when dog the mite was there
that he would surely tell Saul,
I have occasioned the death of all the persons
of your father's house.
Stay with me. Do not be afraid for he who seeks my life,
seeks your life with me.
You shall be in safekeeping.
And so what we see here is a hero in regret.
A hero in regret here.
This is how we know that David was wrong
last week when he went to the priest in the first place.
This is how we know he shouldn't have done it
because he is regretting it that he did it.
He knew this was going to happen
and so he should have just instead trusted God to provide
for him to protect him.
But he tried to work it out
himself, but he didn't trust God.
He trusted himself. He walked some roads that led
to this do outed him.
Hundreds of people died
and David saw it as his fault.
Again, it's the fulfillment of judgment on Eli's house.
But David felt responsible.
It wasn't the end of David's life and career.
He knew God was with him,
but he certainly regretted his actions.
But notice this Abiathar, this new figure introduced here.
Again, still looking back
to chapter two, let's keep that in mind.
He was the one predicted to be spared
Who would eventually, as we walk the rest of this book,
eventually be the one to carry on the priesthood
through David.
Now
As the king Which just finalized the shift
away from Saul, that David now has a prophet
and a priest with him as the new key.
Now I said this earlier,
this is a pretty hard passage.
There's a lot of pain involved.
So many questions raised as we read through this.
And so the question is,
what is this passage even teaching us?
What does this teach us? It's not just moving
to story forward, right?
That's what some narrative does.
It just kind of keeps us going.
This is more, there's more here. What is this teaching us?
I wanna give you three truths today,
three truths that are all separate.
They stand on their own, but they're all interrelated.
Watch this. Here's the first thing we learned
from chapter 22.
We learned that God is sovereign.
God is sovereign.
We don't use that word very often,
but that word simply means he is supreme in
power and dominion.
He is superior to all others.
He does whatever he wants
and he is fully in control of everything.
So when you hear the word sovereign in relation
to God, that's what it means.
He is in charge.
And listen, if you just skim the surface of the Bible,
we cannot deny the reality
of God's sovereignty over all things.
That he is the supreme one.
He is God almighty, anything less than that,
he's not God anymore.
Yet even as I say that,
that raises a couple questions, doesn't it?
If we just stop and think
and we stop to, to look around at the world,
look at if God is sovereign,
then then why do evil things happen?
If he is sovereign and evil things happen?
Well that must mean he's not good then
it's a common question or
or maybe this side there there's a similar related question.
If God is sovereign, if he's in control of everything,
then we're just robots then, right?
Like we're just going through this thing
as ordained and everything.
Those are common questions we get.
That's why the twin truth is
that humans are responsible.
God is sovereign and humans are responsible.
And somehow in God's sovereignty, those
mesh together and it's at this
point where the really hard
and confusing questions start to crop up, right?
Like we try to understand in our limited minds how this,
these twin truths actually supplement one another
and work together.
Because here's the tendency, we tend
to emphasize one at the expense of the other,
but the Bible will not allow us to do that.
In fact, our passage today is actually pretty helpful
to understand this better.
See, like I said earlier, Saul
Dogue, even David
to a lesser extent, were all fully
responsible and stand guilty for the murders
of the priestly families.
They will not be able to stand
before the judgment seat of God
and say, well listen, it is your sovereignty.
They won't. They are responsible for their actions.
Yet at the same time,
God was utilizing their evil desires
to bring about his bigger plan in the judgment
of Eli's family.
None of the people involved are innocent in their evil
sinful decisions.
Yet God was able to bring about his will even
through the sinful evil decisions of those people.
And this was not the first time that that had happened.
This is not new when you read the Bible, think
of young Joseph back in Genesis.
He was sold into slavery by his jealous brothers.
He goes through intense pain the majority of his life,
yet God was with Joseph
and God had a plan that involved Joseph rising
through the Egyptian ranks to where he eventually gets to
where he's running the whole country tree.
And when his starving brothers come to him
to find food from this man
that they had no idea was their brother,
this man they thought was dead long ago.
They come to him. Listen to what Genesis 50 verse 20 says.
Joseph looks at them
and says this, as for you,
you meant evil against me.
But God meant it for good to bring it about
that many people should be kept alive as they are today.
You meant evil.
You tried and did commit evil against me,
but God meant all of that actually for good
to bring about the salvation of a whole lot of people.
See, here's what it as hard as it is for us to do.
We must zoom out of the momentary issues and struggles
and problems and evil in our lives and in our world.
And we must remember that God has a plan.
God is working his plan. It does not hear me.
It does not exempt us from the responsibility each
of us have for what we do in our lives, how we choose
what we say, all of that.
But it must all be balanced by the fact
that God is sovereignly working out his plan.
See, here's, here's where I think maybe we land.
Whenever we talk about like
and debate this a lot about humans having freedom,
we want free will we talk about those
kinds of things like that?
Maybe what we're really craving is autonomy,
that we can act fully on our own.
That we are our own master.
We're in charge of everything in our lives.
Here's the problem with that.
We can never truly be autonomous.
We can never truly act on our own.
We're never free from outside influences.
We are never free from that.
In fact, we never could be free from that.
So our freedom has
to operate within the sphere of something outside of us,
within the framework of something outside of us.
And God has purposed our freedom to operate within
the sphere of his sovereignty,
underneath his sovereign plan that he's working out.
That's how our freedom operates underneath that.
And and when you think about it, right?
That's what's mind blowing about this
in his sovereignty underneath his control, he's built into
that our freedom, our choices.
I don't understand how that works out, but he has done it.
So what that means is we are not robots.
We are not robots.
But he's also not up there merely responding to
what we are choosing in the moment.
Like he's playing some kind of cosmic whack-a-mole game
that he's just saying, well,
I gotta stay ahead of him one step at a time.
Like, and we're just choosing stuff
and he's trying to figure out how to do it
as we're doing it.
That is called open theism.
And that is horribly wrong
because what that means is that God's not in control.
He's merely responding to us in some final way.
We are in control at that point. We don't want that, do we?
I don't wanna be in control of this universe.
I wanna serve a God that knows the future, that knows
how we're going in this way.
Like I, otherwise it's all chance
and it's like based on what you do
and I do in this boom, we,
we have no idea where that's going.
So since that doesn't work, we have to come back to this,
this tr, these twin truths that are undeniable truths,
yet unexplainable friends, that God is sovereign
and humans are responsible.
God is sovereign, humans are responsible.
What that means is that we have no right
to blame God for our sin.
We have no right to blame God for evil in the world
or that he's somehow not good
or he's somehow not in control.
We cannot do that. Instead, we need to humble ourselves.
We need to realize that he is God.
We are not, and that we can know there's
so much we don't understand that we need
to just trust him when we don't get it.
Because there is actually a third interrelated truth here
that we can't forget in this whole conversation,
when we talk about evil, the question comes up about evil
and pain and sin and all these things.
It's common. You're thinking about it right now.
You're trying to process it even in the moment.
Yes, but there's a truth we cannot forget here.
And the fact is that Christ is the
redeemer God.
God is sovereign, humans are responsible,
but Christ is redeemer Because listen,
it would be really easy for us to look around the world and
and see the carnage supported by evil in the world or,
or we look at how messy our lives are
and we could get discouraged by that
or we could get hopeless and start
to feel hopeless about things.
We could start to doubt God in the middle of all of this,
but we don't have to because we have a redeemer.
We look at one Samuel 22
and we look at the gross sin of murder all over that.
And we think, well, what's the answer to that?
The answer is, Christ. We look at our own sin
and we see how, how tempted we are
and how nasty our history is, and we look at that
and like, what's the answer to that?
It's Christ. We look at the brokenness of our world.
We, we look at war and evil and we look, we see abuse,
and we see greed, and we see racism
and we wonder what the answer is to all that.
The answer is Christ.
And I know some of you're thinking, well,
that's just a non-answer, right?
It's just what you say to everything.
It's the Sunday school thing, right?
What's, what's the answer to every question? It's Jesus.
That's not just a simplistic,
let me show you why Jesus is the answer.
He's the answer for our sin.
Because God in his eternal, check this out,
how this ties together with all this.
In his eternal plan of salvation, He worked
through evil to bring about good.
We saw with Joseph, we see it here
because here's, here's what Acts two says.
It clearly states that those
who murdered Jesus were fully responsible for the sin
That They committed.
Yet Isaiah 53, verse 10 says, it was the will
of the Lord to crush him.
It was God's plan from
before time began to have God the Son take on flesh,
Jesus be executed, God working
through the sinful decisions of humans
to bring about the redemption of humans from their sin.
You see that like God is the answer
to sin Christ, the answer to sin.
But that's not all. Here's how Christ is the answer
to the evil and the brokenness in our world.
When you look at how broken things are, the murder here,
Christ came not only to save sinners, he also came
to fulfill the plan of God to redeem all of creation.
Romans eight says that creation itself is eagerly waiting,
even groaning for redemption
because there's coming a day,
even creation it's baked into it knows
that someday is coming, when
creation will be set free from its bondage to corruption
that things don't work right.
It'll be set free from that
and there'll be no more evil anywhere.
Like we look at the carnage here of one Samuel 22,
we look at the wickedness
and difficulty in the world around us.
We look at what tempts us every single day.
The beauty is that we know the end of the story here,
That God will judge evil,
that God will renew creation
and God will take his people home to a perfect eternity.
To someday see those
of us who've trusted in Christ for salvation,
we will be redeemed, we'll be restored,
and we will be safe forever.
Where none of this stuff can even touch us anymore.
'cause it doesn't even exist anymore.
So what do we do while we wait for that?
We work for justice, we work for holiness.
Absolutely we do that. Yes, every day we should.
But ultimately, you ought to be comforted
by the fact that you trust a God who is sovereignly working
all things for the good of those who love him.